Hello Katya stinger for seo
This rider October,
right? I went to Japan for the first time in a long time from 16th to 24th. It
was a
lot of fun.
I asked Japan for
the first
time in 9 years.  I also made a video in Japanese. There, I went to
8 buildings in the environment of studying English in Japan, and chair rattan-style video
. 70 stores that are excessive for Eiken, more than necessary.  With the emphasis
I made a video that probably meant that Japanese people in Japan didn't feel very good about studying English, and I had
some
comments on this tea.
On the other hand,
I'd like to explain why I'm a little careful today.
Why is it the best?
Something is necessary and
such a test nimes can measure the level of the person who studies
it.
There was a comment saying that it is necessary. Another comment is
such a test. Preparing for that is
the person who studies.  There were two comments like that that it was a very big character ration for
me, but
I want to make it a little more paradise and study Kotowa a little more.
That's certainly one way to do it
, and I think it's a very good way to erase it. That's
listening. It's a
test that measures the power of Baek, the ability to read, and the ability to roll.
That's why it's said in English Stinkamp edition.
Good or reading ability.
That ability to read and understand quickly
.  If it's very high, it's
the ability to talk and it
can be developed quickly. The reason
is that the receiving and
b people are good because there is a big agreement and then the word is good but I'm already used to it.
In other words, studying words means studying various data when studying medical science.
It's
not a body, but if you can get used to the pelvis when studying, you can get used to it.
How can that new word be used?
There is a
stop No. A Labo No. Kuruko
5 Every day I listen to these three words
a lot and read a
lot, and then there is a lot of stimulation for that Noh.
It's the result of the stimulators of various spirits. It's
an opportunity to get used to it. I'll definitely study.
Ruro The power to remember isn't very useful in most cases.
Read a lot more slowly, listen a lot, and your brain
naturally gets used to it.
And
that strange book.
Agree and experience I've heard a lot I
wish I could have a habit of listening to English and understanding by reading. Because the
toeic exam isn't a very
easy and easy problem.
Rather than focusing on what kind of question you will be asked,
listen a lot, read a lot, and get used to it.
Look at the question of the person and cut
it off.  There is an image that is all clearer than that. To
that level that you can understand naturally,
you should develop slowly for his own language,
and the 25th comment was made.  It's that the scalp is
motivated to study that preparation for it, which
may be the case for Alf meets, but
stronger motivations are
read and interesting
to read and listen to.  Have fun, whether it's history,
music, songs,
literature,
that melody drama on TV, or something like that
, enjoy it with
something like that, listen
again, read it again, and deliberately
study this  It ’s not like I ’m doing it, it ’s interesting.
-Tee Yonesho is much stronger.
Ah, it's also precious.
Smatter: If you don't enjoy studying in Germany, then I'm more than external pressure or
obligatory feelings.
It's necessary
to be motivated to have toeic because it's inherently much stronger than
that,
but the problem is how to prepare for that question, Toho, or Eiken.
After all, it's definitely more effective to
listen and read a lot every day
, give a stimulus to the brain that isn't enough, and get used to new words little by little
.
Then, from now on,
this is by Cooper's Tuesday morning, but
I'm thinking of doing a Japanese video about once a week before that regular
. Then everyone's next talkie
[Music] Hmm
[  Music
] Hmm